i'm rapping about the whole gate
windmill i don't even care what you guys
are saying
this is great we thought we'd do
something uh
fun and rappy using your um screen
sharing ability we're gonna rap about
wikipedia's random articles
uh so what i wanna do is
he's gonna do press random article and
then everyone watching
give me a thumbs up or thumbs down just
in real life
if you want me to rap about that article
so let's get that first one thomas
okay thumbs up if you want a rap about
imperial schrade
no wow really wildly unpopular guys come
on they're an american knife
manufacturer of hunting nice pocket
knives utility knives and bayonets
what about queslac and jolpha sam and
joseph
okay there's quite a few thumbs up here
okay god did you guys all live in
queschlach
this is great so this is a freestyle rap
about questlac and jolpha
i'm excited for this great let's uh drop
a fun little piece this is
mad alright let's do it okay
i'll make it up i never plan coming out
to joffa that's a province in iran east
azerbaijan kind of weird that the
country name intersects even though the
country borders ain't the same
how many families 187 2006 the census
i'm in heaven cause the numbers are
perfect
674 let me break it down by mathematics
well
more than i can do it in my brain yeah i
think back to the family holiday i had
in quest like
i was like yeah i drank back a few and
then a question why is it spelled
without the you
surely you need that correct with the
grammar a village there oh i go visit my
grammar i say sup glad to be
here in the time zone 3.30 across the
universe so yes i know
kind of weird kind of strange maybe i
presume it's got a little mountain range
if you're going up to the north west see
you on the map there we go that's a
questlac freestyle rap that's the quest
like freestyle
okay cool next thing let's see if we
like this article let's see what we're
gonna get here um
okay right this thumbs up from scott
there's thumbs down from john thumbs
down from
remus this is kind of 50 50 okay there's
probably more than not
tell you what what we'll do let's do
random article again and you can always
click back if we don't
like the next one more
uh [ __ ] you this is a dictatorship i'm
rapping about the whole gate windmill i
don't even care what you guys are saying
this is great um this is a lot
of article for a windmill okay
let's do this
look in there gazing out the windowsill
beautiful landscaping then i spy that
mill i say wow i wanna get closer so i
can touch
i felt like i was dutch because they
love the windmills
but they don't talk like shish i'm over
here whole gate in york
north yorkshire oh it's out of order but
they fixed it
everybody said there's more to north
yorkshire than having just a windmill
how many little fans on there five still
like the fingers on the hand glad you
asked me oh situated slightly south of
haxby
when was it built memories plenty the
brick stones by george ward 1770
ben h and grew up there he's like ill
i love the rap about the windmill chris
spilled the beans the grandson
of george and his son ran the mill until
1851
19th century roughly thereabouts and
then they
erected a dwelling house and let me tell
you about this without
fail rolling reefer sales were replaced
hard as nails get the double patent
like the leather and then a fourth pair
of stones move it down thomas want some
more going
on a large electric motor replace the
steam engine
that's the real shame guys you should be
clenching your anuses and saying that's
not how it should work
pair of millstones four pairs i don't
shirk responsibilities pay attention
out of wars covered in a new lime render
name
light bender come from futurama got a
finial on top
yeah i don't alarm you that's the little
ball that they top
on the top of the eaves working one day
out of the week 75 kg a whole meal and
spelt flour that feels like a [ __ ]
production and a glower like i'm putting
my brows down
look at those pictures description of
the mill machinery we're still here
who could have thought it would go on
for so long that's the whole gate
windmill song
okay right let's do one more because
these are these are very much
self-indulgent
uh it feels similar to a windmill
doesn't it guys what are we voting on
this
yet oh my gosh are we like i should
check cause i don't want to be a
dictator anymore yes there's enough
thumbs up here to do this
great stuff the list of awards and
nominations received by joseph
gordon-levitt
oh yes can can you um can we scroll down
and just see how many he has
my christ look at that mostly nominated
sorry joseph gordon
um fantastic let me tell you guys don
john i think when
thomas is a film film scholar you teach
film at university
uh um what is don john good
uh i haven't seen it but it's about porn
so yes
okay cool let's uh rap about this i'm
gonna drop
uh drop a little beat here this is kind
of chill i like this
um we're gonna wrap up all of these
i'm excited maybe scroll back up a
little second thomas just so we can just
make sure we remind ourselves his
smug little face look at that face oh
he's so handsome
i'm so jealous jealousy towards jg
is pathetic got a double-barrel name
that's the gordon and the levitt
look at him so self-assured frustrated
he's nominated but no awards get one
and i'll take you through his career
he's an actor and a filmmaker but one
little thing with his slick back hair
who would have known he was an
entrepreneur
child actor river runs through it
looking at the big screen like he's
gonna do it gonna prove it
everybody was revealed 94 he'd be
starring in angels in the outfield
got a saturn award and young artist for
the hunger success he was starving
third rock from the sun on the tv do it
as a child you know kind of teeny
not about porn though that's the wrong
one later on 2013 to the don john
this way where to begin challenging
roles that mysterious skin
never viewed it so the plot that's in
ain't in there but he'd be kicking up a
din you can
no rom can't make a bummer when you're
getting in the 500 days of summer why is
that parenthetical around that number
breakthrough actor got his skills
discovered but more to the future
unpleasant over in the film chicago
seven with the aaron sorkin writing
there on the script
sacha baron cohen yeah he sticked it
right to joseph because he got
ensemble announcement with the speech so
humble
hey guys i'm jgl whoa winning this award
is total swell i'm really happy
why cause it's been a while i haven't
got any award but if you are a child and
you're watching
a show can't be beat daytime emmy awards
for sesame street
50th anniversary outstanding host you're
a certainty
like a shoe-in but he didn't get it oh
make you feel sad most of his awards
wore breakthrough
and this one out of the best selection
cheers for that best fight it was in
inception best kiss
shared with elliot page biggest badass
star
turn the page on that [ __ ] biggest
badass star what the [ __ ] can you click
on that link thomas maybe look it up
what the heck does that mean we can
guess biggest badass star that's the bbs
back to o6 best hero jessica alba yeah
we know beaten by christian baler was
bruce wayne daniel radcliffe got the
harry potter
on the brain beating chris evans and
chris hemsworth do they get cash prizes
what's the check worth
martin freeman has bilbo big and badass
yeah he'll be talking bout his toes
cause they're so large you can wake up
early to beat cable that's unexpected
journey
look at this so revealing what's the
maze runner everybody just stealing
these awards from chris pat and shailene
woodley
jennifer lawrence katniss everdeen we
can keep reading words off the table but
we won't cause the beat's done
there we go who would have thought that
we'd end up rapping about biggest badass
stars